WE ARE FOX NEWS AND WE ARE ON I
IT.
THEY BLOW ON THE MIDTERM
ELECTION.
ONE OF THE RACES THAT WE ARE
STILL TALKING ABOUT IS THE ONE
THAT TOOK PLACE IN GEORGIA.
THE REASON WE STILL TALKING
ABOUT IT IS BECAUSE ONE OF THE
CANDIDATES HAS REFUSED TO
CONCEDE AND THAT HAS GIVEN RISE
TO A CONVERSATION ABOUT
SOMETHING CALLED VOTER
SUPPRESSION.
IT TURNS OUT THAT THEY TURN OUT
AND THE GEORGIA 2018 ELECTION
WAS DRAMATICALLY UP OVER PAR
MIDTERM YEARS.
57% OF REGISTERED VOTERS TURNED
OUT.
THAT COMPARES TO LESS THAN HALF
OF 2010.
AND YET DESPITE THAT THE
DEMOCRAT OF THE RACE, STACY
ABRAMS HAD THE ELECTION WAS
STOLEN FROM HER BECAUSE THE
BOATS WERE SUPPRESSED.
HERE'S PART OF WHAT SHE IS
SAYING.
>> IT WAS NOT A FREE AND FAIR
ELECTION.
IT WAS NOT FAIR TO THE THOUSANDS
WHO WERE FORCED TO WAIT AND LONG
LINES.
>> IS HE THE LEGITIMATE
GOVERNOR?
>> HE IS THE PERSON WHO WON AN
ADEQUATE NUMBER OF VOTES.
>> Tucker: AN ADEQUATE NUMBER
OF VOTES, IN OTHER WORDS MORE
VOTES.
JUST A WELL CONCEIVED AND SET
HER PACK HAS FILED A LAWSUIT
ALLEGING THAT PHRASE, VOTER
SUPPRESSION.
WHAT EXACTLY IS VOTER
SUPPRESSION?
A FORMER ADVISOR TO THE
HILLARY CLINTON FAMILY AND
CAMPAIGN JOINS US NEXT.
RICHARD, THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US.
I AM TOTALLY OPPOSED TO VOTER
SUPPRESSION, AND FOR DEMOCRACY.
I ALWAYS HAVE BEEN.
I THINK THIS IS WORTH LOOKING AT
CAREFULLY.
I AM HUNG UP ON THIS LOGIC
BARRIER.
IF VOTER TURNOUT WAS HIGHER THAN
IT HAS BEEN IN THE PREVIOUS TWO
ELECTIONS, HOW DID THAT PLAY A
ROLE?
>> YOU ARE ENOUGH OF A SCIENTIST
TO KNOW THAT CORRELATION DOES
NOT PROVE CAUSALITY.
LET ME QUOTE.
>> Tucker: WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN?
>> THERE WAS A HIGH TURNOUT ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY.
HERE ARE FIVE THINGS THAT
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS AND
LEGISLATORS DID TO SUPPRESS THE
VOTE OVER THE PAST THREE YEARS.
THEY CLOSED POLLING PLACES, THEY
PURGED ELIGIBLE VOTERS.
VOTER I.D. WAS REQUIRED WHICH
CUTS AGAINST INNER-CITY OFTEN
MINORITY VOTERS.
EARLY VOTING WAS ELIMINATED IN
STATES FOR EARLY VOTING
TYPICALLY FAVOR DEMOCRATS.
THE STEPS WERE TAKEN.
WITHSTANDING THAT,
CONGRATULATIONS.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THERE WASN'T
ANY VOTER SUPPRESSION.
TO.
>> Tucker: ACTUALLY, DOES MEAN
THAT.
VOTER SUPPRESSION IS A
SEPARATION OF VOTES BUT STACY
ABRAMS GOT MORE VOTES THAN ANY
DEMOCRAT IN TEN YEARS THE STATE
OF GEORGIA.
SHE GOT MORE VOTES THAN
HILLARY CLINTON GOD WAS RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT IN 2016.
WHERE ARE THE VOTES THAT WERE
SUPPRESSED?
SHE WENT TO HISTORIC NUMBER OF
VOTES.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
MAYBE THERE WERE ATTEMPTS MADE
THAT THEY DIDN'T WORK BY
DEFINITION.
>> YOU COULD HAVE BETTER
PATCHING AND STILL HAVE MORE
HOME RUNS.
WE KNOW THAT HE ATTENDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO WERE
INELIGIBLE.
SPEW AND NO ONE IS CLAIMING THEY
WERE TOO KNOWLEDGEABLE.
THEY DIDN'T MATCH THE IDs.
THERE VOTER REGISTRATION DID NOT
MATCH.
THAT IS THE LAW OF A STATE OF
GEORGIA.
>> THAT WASN'T THE ONLY REGION.
THERE ARE POLLING PLACES THAT
WERE CLOSE.
THERE ARE VARIOUS STEPS THAT
WERE TAKEN.
>> Tucker: WHEN WILL YOU
CONCEDE THAT AFRICAN AMERICANS
VOTED IN THE SAME PROPORTION
THEY HAD IN PREVIOUS ELECTIONS
IN THE STATE OF GEORGIA.
THEY DID NOT DETECT ANY DROP-OFF
IN BLACK VOTING.
HER NUMBERS FOR THE HIGHEST OF
ANY DEMOCRAT IN TEN YEARS.
WILL YOU AT LEAST CONCEDE THAT
MAY BE VOTER SUPPRESSION IF IT
EXISTED WASN'T VERY EFFECTIVE?
>> NO.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
>> YOU CAN LAUGH.
IT TELLS YOU SOMETHING WAS GOING
ON TO ACTUALLY SUPPRESS IT.
WHEN I SAY CORRELATION DOESN'T
PROVE CAUSALITY, THE MERE ACTION
THAT IT WAS --
>> Tucker: ARE BLACK PEOPLE
REQUIRED TO PILFER BLACK
CANDIDATES?
>> THEY TEND TO.
SPEW AND CHECK WITH THE LAW?
WHAT ARE YOU SAYING.